use the commutative law of addition let
me underline that the commutative law of
addition to write the expression 5 plus
8 plus 5 in a different way and then
find the sum now this commutative law of
addition sounds like a very fancy thing
but all it means is if you're just
adding a bunch of numbers it doesn't
matter what order you add the numbers in
so we could add it as five
plus eight plus five we could order it
as five plus five
plus eight we could order it eight plus
five plus five these are all going to
add up to the same things and it makes
sense if i have five of something and
then i had 8 more then i add 5 more i'm
going to get the same thing as if i had
took 5 of something then added the 5
then added the 8 and you could try all
of these out you'll get the same thing
now they say in a different way and then
find the sum the easiest one to find the
sum of actually let's do it all of them
but the easiest one just because a lot
of people immediately know that 5 plus 5
is 10 is to maybe start with the 5 plus
5. so if you have 5 plus 5 that's 10
plus 8 is equal to
18. now let's verify that these two are
the same exact thing
up here 5 plus 8 is 13
13 plus 5 is also 18.
that is also 18. if we go down here 8
plus 5 is 13 13 plus 5 is also equal to
18. so no matter how you do it no matter
what order you do it in and that's the
commutative law of addition sounds very
fancy but just means that order doesn't
matter if you're adding a bunch of
things